What's the difference between magnesium oxide and magnesium glycine rate?
So there's a whole bunch of different magnesiums on the market.
And so the magnesiums that you'd use would be depending on what your issues are.
So if you're just if you're trying to use magnesium that would
that would like call me your brain. Let's say your issue is you can't sleep at night and you're
up you know a lot and you're trying to call me your brain. Well there's magnesium that you might
like magnesium 3 and 8 and magnesium 3 and 8 that would help the brain call me.
Even magnesium malate can be brain call me. So you take that before bed that's not technically
a magnesium to help you have a bowel movement. Magnesium glycinate or glycinate would be a magnesium
that you would take that you that would help you with a bowel movement. Why? Because it's not
as well absorbed. So it's going to have a tendency to stay in the colon and it's going to help you
with a bowel movement. Magnesium oxide is typically thought of as a poor form of magnesium.
Like the magnesium are magna clear that we have as our private labeled magnesium. This is
cheap as the other magnesium with the benefit of it is that it has three forms of magnesium in it.
So the benefits of having multiple forms of magnesium as it can help with different things.
Now all magnesium is you know the biggest thing about magnesium is you want it to be absorbed. So
magnesium oxide is not as well if you're trying to use it for other things that your body other than
just a bowel movement. So magnesium oxide is thought to be more poorly absorbed magnesium.
There's even magnesium carbonates very poorly absorbed magnesium. But most of the magnesiums
on the market that are mixed magnesium are going to be the magnesium balance and different things
that are going to be better absorbed. So that's what typically what would be recommended.